جت فترة يقولون حطي عصافير في الصالة
أدخل زواج وألاقي أقزام داخلين معي
والأميرة النائمة أو سندريلا، وقامت وراحت تجيب الجزمة
كأني عايشة في فلم رسوم متحركة
اسمي هدى الباز
صار لي تقريبًا 18 سنة في المجال
مخططة أعراس (Wedding Planner)
زوَّجت بنتي فاستعنت بشركة
صراحة كانوا الشركة من ذيك الأيام من 18 سنة
ما كان عندنا الشركات اللي تبرد القلب على قولتهم
خلص الزواج وكنت قاعدة مع نفسي ومتضايقة
أقول ليش كذا؟ ليش ما يكونون متحمسين أكثر؟
يكونون متقنين أكثر، حرفيين أكثر في مجالهم
قررت في لحظاتها أني أبدأ هذا المجال
إذا أنتِ رحتي المنسقة
خلاص مفروض ترمين عليها كل شيء
أنتِ ما تسألين المفروض ولا عن شيء
تستلمين الزواج كامل
الديكور، الضيافة، الصبابات، الفنانين، التصوير
كل هذا تقدر توفره هي
المنسقة توفره للعروس
نجي نحن دائمًا نقولها بس جيبي معاكِ كسرة العود فقط
ولا تعالي أنتِ كأنك معزومة، لأم العروس
لكن إذا أنتِ ما أعطيتي منسق مثلًا
أنتِ بتسوينه بنفسك، ما بتقدرين
إلا وتطلع لك نواقص
إلا ويطلع لك شيء ما بيخطر على بالك
شوفي، المجال هذا دخلوا فيه ناس كثير للأسف
اللي فاهم واللي مو فاهم
يبين أنا لما أجي أقعد مع منسقة الأعراس
لما يجي يقولك بعمل لك وبسوي لك
أبد، تبغين مثل كذا؟ أبدًا أسوي لك وأعمل لك
إذا قالك ما عندي عقود، هذا اهربي منه
معليش، ليش ما عندك عقود؟
لازم يكون عقود، والعقود فيه بنود
وتقرأين عقدك وبنودك زين
لأنه أحيانًا تكون أشياء مبهمة
يجي يوم الزواج، ليش ما حطيت لي أنا معازيمي 200؟
لا، ما قلتِ لنا أن معازيمك 200
والله نحسب معازيمك 100
لازم تقرأين كل بند مضبوط، أيش مكتوب فيه؟
عدد الضيوف، عدد الكنب
مو عدد الكنب، عدد الضيوف ينكتب جنب الكنب
لأنه فيه ناس يحاسبونك على الكنبة
ما كان الناس تعرف أيش يعني إضاءة في الزواج
خلاص كشاف عروس بس وانتهينا
كشاف العروس بدل ما يزيّنها يشيّنها
بدل ما يزيِّن العروس؛ يشينها من جد
لأنه إضاءة بيضاء
فتبيّن تشوهات المكياج
فصاروا يعرفون الحين
صاروا يقولون لا ما نبغى كشاف عروس
نبغى إضاءة من فوق
ديكور بسيط مرة بس كوشة فقط لا غير
الحين لا، وين
الحين كأنك قاعدة تبنين بناء
كأنك قاعدة تبنين فعلًا تبنين
تبنين كوشة، ممرات، مداخل، جدران بالصالة
حتى الصالة صرنا نسوي لها جدران كاملة
عشان نقدر نحط الديكور اللي احنا نبغى عليها
أخت العروس دايمًا هي اللي متطلبة
أبغى وأبغى
تبغى تثبت يمكن وجودها؟
تدخل في موضوع ما له دخل
مثلًا ليش حطيتي هذه الفازة هنا؟ ليش حطيتيها؟
طيب هي العروس اللي طالبتها
أنت ما كنتِ موجودة في الاجتماع اللي نحن سويناه
مثلًا، هذا مو اللون اللي أنا اخترته
أجي أقولها لا هذا هو اللون اللي اخترتيه
قالت أبدًا
طبعًا أنتِ ما تقدرين تشدين معها في يوم الزواج
تقولين أنتِ أيش تبغين؟ تبغين نغيره؟ نغير لك إياه
ترجعين تجيبين لها مثلًا النموذج حق الألوان
أيش تبيغين؟ يلا بسرعة قولي أيش تبغين؟ أي لون؟
ترجع تختار نفس اللون
فتقولي لها حطيت لك نفس اللون
تقتنع تقول أيه صح وهو نفسه موجود
شوفي الزواجات البسيطة اللي نتكلم عليها مثلًا بالبيوت
يكون مرة كوشة صغيرة ناعمة
ترتيبات، طاولات، كنبات، مداخل، أشياء بسيطة
خمسين ألف
فيه ناس يشوفونها مرة كثيرة
خمسين ألف أنه مثلًا عدد ضيوف ستين أو خمسين
بس فيها تكلفة ترى
بالنسبة للزواجات الوسط
ثمانين، تسعين، مئة هذا الوسط
اللي فوق الوسط لا، من 200 ألف وطالع
فيه زواجات توصل مبالغ مو سهلة صراحةً
بس تشوفين أنه فعلًا فيه شغل
جت فترة يقولون حطي عصافير في الصالة
معليش، جت فترة ترى
عصافير أو حمام في الصالة
قد جاتني عروس وطلبت مني هذا الشيء ورفضت أنا
أنه قفص ينفتح وتطير العصافير
عرفتيه؟
جت هذه الفترة
فأنا كنت ضدها تمامًا
ممكن طيور حب، هذا معناته؟
أنهم انطلقوا، ما فهمت
بس تجيك العصافير اللي في الصالة تدور
أيش معنى هذه؟
هذه ممكن تسوي أي شيء في الصالة
اللي تدخلي بعربة مثلًا، عربة سندريلا
واحدة جات قالت لي أبغى الأميرة النائمة؟
أو اللي تدخل الأقزام السبعة
حركات سندريلا
فقلت لها هذه هبة أنتِ تحسينها شيء زين، هبة
كانت ذيك الأيام جت فترة يدخلون بالعربة
قلت لها بس ترى بتتندمين أنك سويتيها
لأنه شيء يضحك
يعني أدخل زواج وألاقي أقزام داخلين معي
والأميرة النائمة وسندريلا، وقامت وراحت تجيب الجزمة
كأني في فلم رسوم متحركة
خليك واقفة عادي، عروسة داخله
عقدي واضح
مجرد ما تقرأ العقد تعرف أنه ما يطلع لها الشغل
إلا قبل الزواج مكمل بأسبوعين المبلغ
بس قد صارت لي قصص مثل كذا أنا
للأسف صارت لي قصة مع وحدة وثقت فيها
طلعت لها زواج كامل على مسؤوليتي أنا
ولليوم ما دفعت
وعدتني إن شاء الله بعد الزواج
أنا عندي ظروف
وبعد الزواج على طول بدفع لك
مر يوم، يومين، ثلاثة، أربعة، خمسة، شهر، شهرين
وأقول أيه إن شاء الله، لا أكيد مستحيل ما تدفع
كيف واحدة تزوج بنتها وما تدفع؟ كيف؟
صارت ما ترد علينا، تتجاهل مكالماتنا
صارت تتهرب
يعني زواج بنتها صار على حسابي أنا
أنا تكلفت بزواج بنتها
شوفي، لو ما أعشق هذه المهنة
ما استمريت إلى الحين
لأني أعشقها وأحبها
لو رجع فيني الزمن بختار شيء شبيه فيها
بس مو هي
أكلت من صحتي
ممتعة وحلوة
وفيها متعة لما تخلصين وتسلمين الشغل
وتكون العروس مبسوطة، وأهلها مبسوطين وسعيدين
تكونين أنتِ معاهم سعيدة
تكون مثلًا انزفت وراحت هي وزوجها
أتفاجأ برسالة منها
مو فاضية لي، كيف ترسل لي الحين؟
ترسل لي بصوت وتشكر ومبسوطة وسعيدة
وأنسى كل شيء أصلًا، أنسى كل التعب
الله يعطيك العافية
الله يعافيك يارب
شكرًا جزيلًا
خلصنا؟
خلصنا
بس أستأذنك، نصفق مثل كذا
كذا؟
عشان هذه نضبط الصوت مع الصورة